everyone I'm Alana and welcome to my
channel today I'm doing another
anonymous Q&A for hitting at 305
thousand subscribers oh thank you guys
so much if anyone who doesn't know or
isn't familiar with this format
basically when I'm ready to take
questions I just tweet out a link to my
tumblr which pulled the record I don't
use it all aside from for this one thing
people can submit whatever they want
anonymously the only questions that I
don't answer or ones I've answered a
million times
ones that I don't have interesting
answers to there is nothing off the
books it gets fun when it's anonymous
though sometimes it's just people being
like how are you like this first one
first question how you doing you I'm
okay I've been very sick lately I
mentioned it a couple of times I have
chronic fatigue which means I am
exhausted and I faint and I get very
dizzy and there are days where I just
kind of can't do anything at all I can't
even walk which aside from like joint
pain and headaches you know it's very
tolerable compared to a lot of stuff
other people go through but it does make
you very miserable so it has been bad
the last couple of days has been good
though so hopefully I'm on the upswing
what's one thing you dislike or hate
about your life that you wouldn't change
ooh interesting question okay I hate
that I am so far from my family but I
wouldn't change it because the industry
that I walk in is in America I don't I
said what's a game you fully expected to
hate but ended up bluffing I think the
best example that I can give of this is
no man's sky where before it came out I
said I thought it would be bad I didn't
think it would have enough content I was
right at the time but then the next
update came out and ever since then I
have adored no man's sky I love it
I'm from Brisbane and I still recently
said you were going home for the
holidays we had question would you ever
have coffee with a fan would love to
discuss video games and how you got to
start in games journalism and such I
mean I've done that at PAX it's like if
someone's come up to me and been like
good would you talk to me about stuff
I'll do it if it's like a young person
interested to get into games journalism
I'll go grab a coffee with them at that
event otherwise I would not meet up with
a stranger on Alman from the Internet
I think the same rules apply as they
apply to everyone else stranger danger
friends regarding funhouse fuen do you
think it'll be difficult to keep videos
on YouTube monetize if they still are
with all the changes YouTube is making
to appeal to advertisers
I think funhouse is okay
comes to monetization when it comes to
the humor it is the content generally
that YouTube is going to screw you over
for and the content of our videos is
still videogames
we just make jokes around those video
games so no I generally think funny
house is fine you miss sure the point
seven honestly I do I miss them being in
the office yeah it's nice to have people
around who in my age which I guess now
fly seeing inside gaming team but like
wheat walk around Pokemon go yeah they
were fun to have around
do you miss Bruce I miss Bruce I do miss
Bruce yeah
which body a job you prefer the video
game journalism or the on screen
gameplay antics with funhouse an on
stream definitely the video game
journalism recording game plays it's fun
like we get to just talk about your
gaming loft but the thing that makes me
really passionate really happy is
talking about video games in a serious
capacity I love that that's why I just
started that new podcast gonna talk
about video games once a month that is
the thing that makes me light up like
pretty much nothing else does I just so
passionately love talking about video
games I'm currently studying and
creative entertainment pathway in
Brisbane and just wanted to ask what
kind of study such lush industry type
job you explored before I can fire Janet
fun house you should check out the video
on my channel where I react to old
videos you can see pretty much all of
that information there what is it it's I
don't know what I called it this is also
a problem with the chronic fatigue is my
short-term memory is really bad and I
like get dumped we get rambly that's the
thing the basically the one where I did
I react to old videos watch that or
watch the video on my channel that is
called how I got a job at IGN TP over
under definitely over I will literally
change the toilet paper roll at
someone's house if it something so I'm
aggressive about over what is something
you're still wanting to do that you
haven't had time for yet I mean I'm
writing a book and I have been for ages
I need to finish that goddamn thing but
I don't know how people do it it's tough
it's really tough the starting the
writing part is easy the keeping doing
it is hard I want to buy a used pair of
your panties name your price how much
would I sell used no I think that's a
bad rabbit hole yeah someone asked me to
do that in person once I had a guy come
up to me when I was
17:16 be like how much for the underway
are currently wearing and for whatever
reason I said I'm okay thank you I think
about that a lot
why did I say thank you and I walked
away and I think I said sorry I was so
polite and I was definitely
uncomfortable but I thought about it I
was like man I think he offered me 50
bucks I was like well but then I'd have
to get change or I have to like walk
around with underwear without honor
where the rest of the days like a whole
thing having seen you in a lot of
content recently I can only assume
you've been walking harder that makes me
wonder do you feel as though 2019 it's
been great yeah a few both personally
and career-wise and when you say that
the key is 5 appearance was the perfect
intertwining of the two I do not feel
like 2019 has been a great year for me
personally or career-wise this year has
been like a halt on everything and no
the gives five appearance is so minor I
just play some like mine and PCs but
like I'm so stoked to have been able to
do that it's very cool treat for me but
it is not at all like a sense of
accomplishment or like a you know huge
career step it was just a cameo like a
very small couple of cameos
I'm not unrealistic about that like I it
means a lot to me as a fan but as a
professional it does not if that makes
sense I don't want to sound ungrateful
but that's how I look at stuff at least
if given the chance would you have a
host the game once totally yeah what's
the meaning of life 42 most attractive
feature on a man oh I don't know about
most attractive but lips are really
important to me
gotta have full lips that that means it
goes a long way mm-hmm
did I see you in the special feature
section on the venom blurry during a
motorcycle jump stunt yes
oddly phrased question but yes I am on
the venom special features I went there
for IGN and they caught my face doing a
thumbs up whoo oh boy sometimes anxiety
of of how is my ability to just fully be
myself because I think about every
possible negative outcome you seemed
very genuine in your attitude even in an
online environment you'd be toxic in
brutal any advice I'm just letting go of
that anxiety and being comfortable with
acting yourself I do not suffer from
anxiety at all I get anxious about very
bad things that happen like extremely
bad things and then I'll get
overwhelmingly anxious about like what
is the outcome of this going to be
is going to happen but day to day life I
definitely can't give you advice for
this as I am a human who almost has the
opposite of anxiety I rarely get nervous
I'm always comfortable being myself so
I'm sorry I definitely am not equipped
to answer this one you so fun house I
haven't seen you in the videos lately
but maybe I'm just blind yeah I mean
I've been on well so I will be on camera
lists I think I'll be on camera less
that going forward but I'm definitely
still with fun house definitely still on
camera people started freaking out as
soon as I wasn't in a video for seven
days it's nuts watch your favorite movie
of 2019 parasite do you have a go-to
karaoke song chop suey by System of a
Down do you have a question society in a
backwards way that we live all the time
like for reals Christmas is about
feeding a corporate machine to keep us
in debt and poverty and has actual no
significance these these days I don't
agree with that about Christmas but yeah
there are plenty of things that I
question constantly like I kind of hate
Disney so there are a lot of things that
I keep away from the internet which is
like how aggressively anti-capitalist
but really only in the entertainment
industry am I'm aggressively against
been awfully 'z Disneyland makes me
uncomfortable because I hate that it's
so clearly designed to make people who
don't even necessarily have money spend
way more [ __ ] money than they should
advertising everywhere much everywhere
and then they sell it to you like the
happiest place on earth like that I hate
that but I try to not talk about that
stuff on the internet cuz it's a bit
much sometimes I'm too woke but like not
the nest jwa just in are like very aware
of capitalism way for the record in some
cases capitalism can be good but any
entertainment industry it makes me a
couple wide a beautiful women usually
act like they aunt that's being humble
and then there's lying I mean I assume
you're directing this at me and I can
give you perspective on this thing I
don't think there are many people in the
world who genuinely believe they are
beautiful I would not consider myself to
be beautiful and none of that is to do
with being humble or what other people
think of me thinking that because I
don't weigh it that highly I care much
more about brains than I care about
looks but I think that there is probably
no person on the planet who wakes up and
thinks they are beautiful every single
there if there is it's a very small
minority of people or it's the people
who have had plastic surgery to get rid
of everything
I hated about themselves I just don't
think that really exists breath of the
wild us is ready at redemption -
definitely breath of the wild red dead
redemption - is a great game but
definitely breath of the wild only gives
a hilarious loss thank you
I enjoy watching a game play stuff when
you tube on your live streams I feel
that soon I have a question also what's
your favorite movie look [ __ ] I think
it's super 8 but I haven't seen it in a
really long time so I could be wrong
I feel very passionately about primal
you know what it might be the Fellowship
of the Ring yeah what do you need in a
partner what do I need I think I'm
pretty low maintenance and I'm told that
I'm very low main and so easy to date
but I think they're probably all things
I need I need reassurance I need to feel
attractive so sometimes that's
compliments and affection that's
probably it like I need a good cuddle
that makes me feel good you definitely
need to feel like I'm important too so
like having stuff about someone's life
shared with me and not feeling like I
don't I think that's kind of it yeah
sense of humor is probably really
important to me - what's your most
anticipated game of 2020 damn dude a
hell of a year I'm already terrified
it's gonna be [ __ ] nuts I'm gonna say
cyberpunk right now how would you
describe your boobs
did you think I'd going to like graphic
details so you could masturbate they're
great I like them do you think Henry
Cavill should get another shot at
Superman with these recent interviews
going around should they go for Matt
Reeves and stuff fresh yeah start fresh
I know think Henry Cavill was ever
really right for Superman he looks right
but I don't think his performance was
ever right so I don't think he fits the
bill for that one what was your favorite
game of 2019 which gave me most excited
for 2020 2019 is Sakura 2020 like I said
it's cyberpunk but I'm really excited
for Costa Tsushima of course the Last of
Us 2 is a huge deal it's really a bunch
of stuff I'm forgetting what's the one
thing that you want for Christmas Alana
Tim Tams
I don't want gifts anymore I have
everything and if I want something I
just quiet and I keep trying to convince
my family to not spend money on me
not just won't stop they would prefer to
not have anything but yeah I always want
Tim Tams every birthday every Christmas
their Australian biscuits
I [ __ ] love them how long have you
been in the u.s. are the Santa creepy
it's just a question curious jutsu I
believe Australian accent
five years is it true you have a nose
job it is not it's funny I either get
you've had a nose job I think it's
because of the shape of my nose because
it like tilts up or I get you know it's
too [ __ ] big get a nose job it's one
or the other
hello on with so many project on your
table would that affect your upload
schedule on your own channel yeah it
does all the time the thing that gets
cut if I'm busy is streaming first I'd
stream maybe once every two weeks at the
moment and then YouTube videos so I try
to like record in bulk or pre record
some of them but yeah because YouTube is
not any good it's not an income
generator for me it doesn't make me very
much money at all it's sort of the thing
that I have to drop favorite gift you've
received from a fan there was a girl who
sent me a care package I think when she
found out I was going through health
stuff that had like bought bombs and a
book and some incense and I thought it
was just really sweet I'm just very
considerate thing for someone to do this
one I don't know why people don't
believe it is so funny okay you've
actually have a new boyfriend are you
lying to protect yourself from stalkers
or whatever honestly I don't know why
but I don't believe it's so funny to me
yes I absolutely have a boyfriend but
people keep being like she's definitely
lying she doesn't have a boyfriend I
posted a thing where I was like date
night on my Instagram story and some
people like oh did she take a cell phone
a date it's so weird because it's like
watching people believe that they would
they would want to ask me out but not
believe that I could possibly be in a
relationship just because I haven't
shared the details of it so [ __ ]
strange are you and other women
attracted to guy ass as much as men are
attracted to woman ass I can't speak on
behalf of other women but I am not
sexually attracted to men sauces I can't
find them cute though like I'm being
like nice cute but have you seen your
own rule 34 I have I think I looked it
up for the first time ever at fun house
like while we were recording a gameplay
but otherwise people send me stuff a lot
frankly the frequency at which people
send me something and I like oh my god
this picture of you leaked when it's
just another edit is is nuts
happens with deep fakes too I had it
just last week some guy was like Ilana
this is very serious this video if you
sends me a link and it's just a deep
fake it even said in the video that it's
a deep fake but yeah I have it has no
effect on me really I know it's not my
body so it's not a doesn't feel
violating people always ask is it creepy
or flattering and the answer is honestly
neither it's definitely not flattering
men will masturbate to literally
anything that's also not my body like I
don't think people being attracted
sexually attracted to you is flattering
for the most part because it's like some
of you out here [ __ ] dogs what I
don't and I guess it's yeah I don't find
it creepy because it's not really me I
guess I don't know I don't care and I
just got back to last one that was for
my loss Q&A so that's all of them
friends but I want to thank you so much
for subscribing I will see you guys next
time